chamber of commerce are case
median 1 on the keyboard switzerland
decided
enough
[music]
enough other people interested
sometime second that's it yes that
's it he will watch singing if if
you can't ignore it anymore if you can't
ignore it the only
possibility  when driving can't i
can't i can't call
how about because they don't give you my
phone number
the sad thing about it i have to jump this hateful
comment onto the street so
that a pig is interested
[music]
the monitoring of vienna's
past has also
shown that twitter has a very poor
record of removing illegal
content.
we demand from twitter, as well as from
google and facebook and other social
networks, that when you are made aware of
illegal content
, users who check it  and in the
event that they are illegal then
also  quickly internal
[music
] someone put me in an ss uniform three
with photoshop that makes me happy
as grandchildren surviving a great phase
when they
shock me because i'm supposed to
behave like that